good evening the pandemic has brought a
number of challenges to our world but
one many people didn't expect was a
spike in liver disease
thanks for joining us i'm denise feldas
and i'm brian loftis it's due in part to
an
alarming rise in alcohol consumption 8
news now reporter madison kimbrough
spoke to a doctor
who says in his decades of practice he's
never seen it
this bad she's live with more madison
yes this is a sad sad reality for
hospitals all over the country as more
and more people are being diagnosed with
liver related illnesses
and the age range of those recently
diagnosed is startling
everything has been affected by this
pandemic and that has led a lot of
people who were actually doing fine and
stable
and had kicked their habit going back to
drinking it's a phenomenon seen
all over the country as hospitals report
a dramatic spike in alcohol-related
entries
for critical illnesses like liver
disease the reason
experts say people are turning to
alcohol to cope with the pain of loss
and depression
i've seen people continue to use drugs
even more than they did before
and now the focus is on loss of jobs
of people dying of social interaction
and unfortunately people feel so
isolated so
what they do to cope is they drink and
use drugs there's been a 30
uptick in alcohol liver disease
admissions in hospitals according to dr
sued a gastroenterologist in henderson
who has over 32 years of experience in
the medical field
i had lots of patients with alcoholic
liver disease but they were stable
they were doing fine they were not
deteriorating by any means they were not
heading towards
transplant need for transplant or cancer
but this pandemic has really torn
wrenching things and the age range for
patients is changing too
at an alarming rate the age range is
usually in the adults but interestingly
in the last few months
we've seen more of younger people than
people i would say people in there
anywhere younger than 50 i've had an
alcoholic hepatitis cerealic patient do
a liver transplant
at age 17. yes
according to an la times article the
disease also makes people more
susceptible to covin 19.
patients with liver disease die of covid
19 at rates three times higher
than those without it reporting live
madison kimbrough
8 news now